Kristen New York joins us hi Chris what
do you have I danna first time caller 63
lean 210 pounds Mannix I went in on the
draft eared and um this was Tom
Thibodeau's first draft as as a de facto
general manager and I thought Tom really
embarrassed himself here I mean here's
Tibbs with maybe the best point guard in
the NBA on his roster arguably the most
gifted playmaker of his generation in
Ricky Rubio and he goes and insults
Rubio and basically spits in the face of
the entire Minnesota fan base by daring
to take another point guard in chris
dunn I like Chris done a lot and I'm
just a casual fan here he's big he's a
terrific defender and he has cut from
that Russell Westbrook Derrick Rose mold
but he's not Ricky Rubio and if Tom
Thibodeau trades Ricky Rubio this summer
I think it's going to have the same
catastrophic impact in the franchise
that Shack departure had in Orlando and
lebrons defection from cleveland had on
the Cavaliers back in 2010 and I just
want to get your thoughts on that he's
uh he's Chris Mannix from yahoo sports
you knucklehead you're short on sleep I
know that because you text Pauly at 350
in the morning hey I did want to ask you
though about this Chris what Oklahoma
City did does this have anything to do
with Kevin Durant's future uh it it
wouldn't have been done without um
elicit acid confirmation from Kevin
Durant and then my lay of the land and
and and I'd pick this up over the last
year when they came to to Serge Ibaka is
that the relationship with Serge Ibaka
and the the the bigger teammate there
Westbrook and Durant had become strained
over the past year in large part because
i Baca had sort of been infected by the
same bug if you will that James Harden
and Reggie Jackson did and which means
they mean by that is he wanted a bigger
role and he was not happy just being the
defender the rebounder the shot blocker
which is exactly what Oklahoma City
needed if you look at the last year you
know Serge Ibaka at one point was one of
the best defensive players in basketball
I don't think he got a single vote for
Defensive Player of the Year in this
past year that that's not what what
Oklahoma City needs from from Ibaka so I
had heard that that the relationship
there wasn't great they did expect Ibaka
to eventually leave as a free agent next
summer so this was Sam Presti and the
Thunder trying to get ahead of this and
getting themselves a very good player in
Victor Oladipo it deal for Ibaka yeah I
like Oladipo because he'll play defense
feels like this is a good better than
dion Waiters at this point he's a better
he's a replacement for dion Waiters
there yeah and your matching up against
Golden State you know your moves are to
match up with Golden State let me see
what was the other thing I was gone let
me ask you the poll question more likely
to be an all-star Brandon Ingram or Ben
Simmons see the last time I did this
with you it was Thomas Robinson you
maybe eat it for about five years after
that I got us i would say simmons just
because he's gonna have enhanced
opportunity and so is a brandon eger but
it 70th more nba-ready in ingram it's
gonna take him like a Sean Bradley like
five thousand calorie a day diet which
he's actually on right now he was
telling me about two weeks ago to get
his lower body in his overall body to
can be a strength I I think Simmons is
gonna be special when I was on set last
night with Tom crane who couldn't stop
raving about Simmons and his overall
potential just because how he sees the
floor and and what he can do off the
dribble III think Simmons really you
know it's not LeBron but I think he has
that potential to be a next big star
before I let you go the Celtics what
they were trying to do and what they
settled to do big dot Danny's gonna get
get again kill the Boston right now I
mean he just getting beat up uh this was
incredibly important draft for Boston
and nobody knows me not well this
thing's I hate after the draft and is
winners and losers stuff like yep these
guys that are drafted 20 that nobody can
pronounce their names how do you know
what they're in turn out to be you know
three years from now but I thought the
jail in brown pick was a reach I thought
it was a a sort of a positional pick
they saw themselves with Isiah Thomas at
point guard with Marcus smart a point
guard might take chris dunn the
publisher taken done
and then tried to trade one of those
guys in the offseason Boston was you
know right there aggressive all their
chips on the table trying to get Jimmy
Butler that's what we expected that's
exactly what Boston did everything I
heard from often late last night three
four in the morning was that every time
they tried to make a deal for Jimmy
Butler Chicago just one a little bit
more they couldn't get the Bulls to
accept whatever their last offer was and
ultimately that deal didn't get done the
foreign player the Euro that we will
need to know is who oh god you know I
the one thing I got right during this
draft process and granted is very little
that the people get right in these mock
drafts was uh in George's puppy honest
who nobody had heard of really in up
until yesterday I was getting calls from
executives that were asking me you know
it was was this guy going hi have you
heard anything about this guy going in
the team's he winds up going number 12
12 to Sacramento he could have gone as
high as number 8 to Sacramento but the
Kings moved back it's not going to be
next year but papi honest who is massive
he is a huge huge kid I think down the
line he's going to develop into a top
flight center thank you Chris get some
sleep not that's 12 you're going to make
me eat in five years to why do I even
make this call thank you Chris all right
then that's Chris Mannix the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience